the top business store is live from the
Sky News City Studio
Ryanair chief executive Michael O'Leary
tells Sky News why the carrier has
withdrawn from the Industry Group set up
to promote growth in UK Aviation
a careful approach to the Future despite
record results British manufacturer
Reynold will not be paying a full-year
dividend
and despite economic Gloom one of the
UK's big Hospitality firms tells us why
it expects a bumper summer in the
country's Coastal resorts
[Music]
good afternoon this is business live
with Ian King earlier this year the UK
government set up the UK Aviation
council with the aim of improving the
resilience of the industry promoting
growth and supporting the use of
sustainable Aviation fuels chaired by
baroness fear its members included
National Air Traffic services and the
civil aviation Authority along with
senior Executives from British Airways
EasyJet Virgin Atlantic jet2 Manchester
Airport group Heathrow and Gatwick but
last night Ryanair Europe's biggest
Airline resigned its membership I've
been speaking with Michael O'Leary
ryanair's chief executive to find out
why
yeah because it's useless and doesn't do
anything and we joined it in January
this year when uh the transport
secretary Mark Harper promised this
would be a delivery body for Change and
improving UK Aviation we submitted and
as supported by the other airlines five
requests to baroness beer who chairs the
committee uh shoot the aviation minister
in February we asked for more ATC staff
and not Staffing to improve ATC reduce
the Visa fees uh improve border control
uh Staffing or to reduce passport uh
push for EU EU ATC airspace reform and
she filled nothing for the last six
months we sat through another useless
meeting yesterday where he was
commissioning a working group to look at
a air travel reform it'll be headed up
by those Geniuses that the the CAA and
the department the Department of
Transport officials they report back in
April of next year nothing gets done
instead of doing you know acting on the
simple issues that the airlines won't
resolved like why don't you increase the
Staffing in gnats uh why don't you
reduce the fees I mean they're charging
3 000 pounds for a Visa for a qualified
pilot uh for bringing a pilot to the UK
where there is a shortage of their
pilots we said why isn't that beta 1 000
pounds and she sits there doing nothing
talking about dashboards and action and
all the rest of it but it's all it's
just words it's more incompetent
politicians uh you know pretending
setting up uh talking shops to look like
they're doing something where an extra
pack if you avoids doing anything I mean
it's a very very big Council you've got
many members from right across the
industry the airport operators the
airlines ministers is it just too big
and and um wealthy to be practical
I don't think it's too big but if it was
properly LED would somebody uh who was
committed to actually delivering you
know deliverable change small steps that
would actually improve uh air the
aviation industry in the UK this summer
instead of Byron that's useless uh then
I think you know we'd support it you
know the very simple things that could
be done by uh the transport Department
improve increasing and not Staffing
reduced Visa fees nothing gets done they
just sit there talking about having
workshops and dashboards and really and
while we as the Airlines and our
customers are the victim of you know
appalling ATC today's this summer French
Air Traffic Control we've had 60 days of
strikes already this year five times
more than the same time last year what's
the UK done for to support our campaign
to protect over flights nothing all
inspiring is useless Stone nothing you
know and flights are being delayed
EasyJet last week and I had nothing
Mississippi
cancer 1700 flights from Gaffney because
of these ATC delays and congestion one
has baroness useless Stone nothing once
our Aviation Council done to push for
some reform or protect these overall
Place nothing so frankly we have better
things to do than waste time at a
talking shop of UK politicians and
bureaucrats so we resigned yesterday
we'd go off and run our Airline which by
the way in the UK this year will deliver
13 passenger growth Ryanair will carry
56 million Pastor to and from the UK
this year making us a UK's number one
Airline but thankfully we prefer an
action whereas baroness uses prefers
talking shops and inaction
you mentioned the EasyJet flight
cancellations there you're not worried
that you're going to find yourself in a
similar position at some point this
summer
I mean you know I wouldn't be complacent
uh although you know Reiner we
consciously have over recruited pilots
in cabochu this year you know our
on-time performance is suffering we're
struggling with about 85 on-time flights
normally we'd be about 90
and but you know we are we believe we
have uh more than sufficient pilots and
cabin crew and we're not canceling
fights except on days where there's ATC
strikes uh but I think the on-time
performance for all airlines in the UK
is struggling uh because the government
of the UK government have failed to
deliver any effective reform of ATC
services and the most effective reform
in the near term will be just removable
air traffic controllers so that we don't
have so much congestion and Slaughter
these uh for aircraft entering the
London system it's a mess but
unfortunately uh in Baron is useless we
have an aviation Minister who won't do
anything uh to help the industry resolve
this mess like increase not Staffing and
improve ATC services are you open to
returning to the council
yeah I said my resignation yes it will
return as soon as uh the Barnet Barnes
or an aviation a competent Aviation
Minister actually listens to the
Airlines and acts on the very simple and
deliverable uh kind of asks that we
submitted six months ago I mean there's
nothing simple that increased our
staffing there's nothing simpler than
reducing ludicrous Visa charges of three
thousand pounds to say a more reasonable
one thousand pounds but you know when
you have professional career politicians
like baroness useless you know they
always prefer to be sitting there having
workshops and talking about dashboards
as an excuse for actually doing
something useful and delivering change
and reform for Aviation and UK Aviation
is struggling you know in a post-brexit
environment uh the UK needs to be
smarter and quicker I have some faith in
Mark Harper basic once already I think
he is willing to deliver a change but in
the aviation Minister Baron is uses he
has someone who couldn't deliver a bag
of chips never mind change Aviation
didn't get the sense you liked her very
much to do
now the Cafe and Restaurant operator
loungers today predicted a bumper summer
for traditional coastal towns based on
the trade it seen recently in Resorts
such as clacton-on-sea Western super
Mare and mumbles well the news came as
the company which operates 232 sites
under the lounge and cozy Club Brands
reported record sales of 283.5 million
pounds for the year to the 16th of April
that was up 19 on the previous 12 months
although operating profits fell from 28
million pounds to 14 million pounds as
Government measures to support the
hospitality sector during covid fell
away well joining me now to talk about
this is Alex Riley he's chairman and
co-founder of Lounge as Alex good to see
you are you surprised by this recovery
in coastal resorts
I don't think so I think we've seen it
um we've seen a lot of life in these
towns uh for the last few years so it's
not as if we just opened in all of these
locations we've been shredding quite a
few of them for some time now
um and I think we obviously on the other
side of uh of uh code restrictions or
lockdowns uh ending we saw a lot of
people racing off to uh the sort of
traditional holiday locations in the UK
because obviously international travel
was was very compromised and I think a
lot of these towns are towns that have
probably gone through a very very uh
significant slump and probably have
suffered economically very severely
um primarily because of obviously people
going abroad from the sort of 60s 70s
onwards but you know we're constantly
amazed how some of these towns despite
uh being almost written off by lots of
people are actually really vibrant and
um and have you know we we have a really
good level as a trade in a lot of them
and you're trading in these locations
ahead of where you would be saying City
Center event resorts
yeah indeed I mean as you said we've got
232 sites and and actually seven of our
top 10 performing sites are in these
kind of locations so that's quite a
significant
um uh indicator as to how you know
strong the likes of Western Superman
Torquay mumbles abery Smith You Know
Places which you know should where our
traditional Seaside sounds
um but it's a measure of how well you
can actually trade in these locations
now I should say you're trading from 232
sites you're in expansion mode how many
could the market ultimately sustain do
you think
uh so we've revised our estimate for the
number of Lounge Cafe bars we think you
could trade in the UK um we had always
conservatively talked about 400 but we
now believe that the scope of 600 and
that follows a piece of extensive piece
of work that we've done and obviously
looking at our existing estate and our
knowledge of the UK and understanding
how how many other locations you think
would be suitable
um cozy club we think we can probably
grow to about 75 and we've just launched
a a new Roadside restaurant concept
called Brightside which we've owned the
first two sites uh earlier this year
with the third site to open in August
and that's very much in the lab at the
moment so we'll see uh how that trades
and how different that is and and take a
lot of learnings from the summer and
then potentially consider the possible
scale of that so you know for us as a
business uh we really have got an awful
lot still to go after and that obviously
presents a lot of exciting opportunities
for us and in the Here and Now how are
you managing with some of the headwinds
afflicting the industry the staff
shortages food and drink inflation and
so forth fourth
I think on the starting point I think
it's it's got easier
um it it's by no mean it's easy but it's
easier than it was uh I think the summer
of 2021 was a really low point for us
fatality in terms of uh availability of
staff and I think uh you know we will
have to work harder to attract people we
need to be promoting a more positive
message about the sector I think uh
doing mongering and lots of sort of
negative headlines about Hospitality but
it's a sector that's still in growth we
employ an awful lot of people and it's a
great uh it's a great sector to to
Really sort of elevate yourself up a
career level because you know clearly
for business like ours we're recruiting
um 30 people every 10 days new people so
that gives you a measure of how quickly
we're growing and we've got ambition to
to grow uh even even more uh by more
sites this year than we did the last
year so I think the staff the staffing
issues are abating I think inflation is
something that we're constantly
challenged by I think again that's
probably uh who feels like that's paint
but um I didn't think that you know the
circumstances would find ourselves in
now are certainly easier than they were
five months ago I think okay it needs to
be optimistic Alex gotta leave it there
I'm afraid good to talk to you hope to
see you again thank you
other news now and the bank of England
says the UK's banks will be resilient
even in the event of a severe
deterioration in the global economy and
financial markets the bank warned that
nearly a million mortgage holders will
see their monthly repayments jumped by
500 pounds or more between now and the
end of 2026 publishing the results of
its latest stress tests on the sector
the bank said major lenders have the
capacity to support households and
businesses through a period of higher
interest rates higher Global inflation
recessions in the UK and around the
world materially higher unemployment and
sharp Falls in asset prices the bank
also said the UK economy had so far been
resilient to interest rate Rises but
repeated recent warnings that it will
take time for the full impact of the
increases to come through the lender
stress tested for HSBC NatWest Barclays
Lloyd's Standard Chartered virgin money
Santander UK and Nationwide Building
Society
and staying with banking Barclays has
won an appeal in a Supreme Court ruling
that had it gone the other way could
have exposed the banking sector to
hundreds of millions of pounds worth of
compensation claims the bank had been
sued in 2020 by Fiona Philip a music
teacher and long-standing Barclays
customer who was tricked into
transferring 700 000 pounds into two
bank accounts based in the United Arab
Emirates she claimed that Barclays owed
to a duty of care not to carry out a
payment instruction if the bank believed
those instructions were a result of
fraud the Supreme Court disagreed the
ruling saves the banks from making
compensation payments for so-called
authorized push payment or app fraud
which cost banking customers 583 million
pounds in 2021 alone
now Reynolds may not be a household name
but the chances are the manchester-based
Precision air running Engineering Group
has touched your life in some way its
chains have been used by Britain's medal
winning track cyclists while its
clutches coupling sprockets and
transmission products are used in
sectors as diverse as food manufacturing
and quarrying today it reported a
pre-tax profit of 17.3 million pounds
for the year to the end of March that
was up 39.5 on the previous 12 months
but the shares have fallen by just over
three and a half percent today after the
company declined to pay a full year
dividend who are joining me now is the
chief executive of Reynold Robert
Purcell Robert good to see you this
afternoon
um explain the dividend thinking first
please
I mean it's all about Ian the fact that
it's about the best way to use the cash
within the business we could pay it to
shareholders and we review the benefit
to shareholders of giving them the cash
or using it to add value in terms of
what we can do through Acquisitions or
indeed through capital investment and
development of the business
so this is really you positioning
yourself in the eyes of the market or
trying to as a Growth Company
absolutely we we are looking to develop
the business organically but also
through acquisition and obviously that
requires cash
as you now you complete an acquisition
during the year which has obviously
shown up in the results but what have
you been seeing on an underlying basis
our underlying business is growing very
well though the acquisition of uke in
Spain benefited Us in the year our sales
were up nearly 50 million pounds and
only about 10 million of that just over
10 million of that was due to uke so our
underlying business has been growing
well in terms of Revenue profits and
margins and which of your end markets is
doing best right now
uh the very best Market sector for us
was actually mining inquiry in the year
we almost doubled our Revenue in that
sector all our Market sectors barring
Material Handling actually grew most of
them in the sort of 20 to 30 percent
um sort of area so most of our markets
were pretty resilient over the last 12
months obviously as you say in the
statement you've been grappling with
things like shortages of tux drivers
freight services are those pressure
starting to ease now
yeah a lot of the supply chain pressures
have eased over the last six months or
so things like container prices
availability those types of areas are
all pretty much back to where they were
before the pandemic uh costs however a
slightly different thing steel is still
very expensive energy is not back to
where it was and we do anticipate that
wage costs will be a pressure going
forwards as well
does that mean you're going to come
under a bit of margin pressure over the
coming 12 months or what are you able to
pass on some of that
um we produce a sort of a premium High
specification product it's very good
value for our customers and we believe
that we will be able to pass on those
cost increases to the customers indeed
we've done over the last 12 months our
operating profit margin was up 200 basis
points in the last Financial year now
obviously the US is your biggest single
Market uh Sterling right now is trading
at a more than 15 month High against the
US dollar How concerned are you about
that
uh it's going to be a headwind it was a
benefit to us uh last year it's going
back to the sort of level it was a year
or so ago we believe we can cope with
that a lot of our product is made in
Europe and exported to America it's more
the translation impact that I think will
be a will be an issue to us going
forwards but I'm sure we'll be able to
cope with that as we have done in the
past
all right Robert Gonna Leave a busy day
results day we do appreciate you
spending the time to chat thank you
thank you very much
still to come here on business live or
have a look at how the markets have
finished up this Wednesday afternoon
stay with us
[Music]
I'm Becky Johnston a Sky News
correspondent part of the team based
here in the Midlands
allegations of exploitation in
leicester's clothing factories aren't
new in fact it's been an Open Secret in
this city for years
[Music]
made for people who want Clarity in an
uncertain world
getting more and more stabbing and
essentially I think it's more my younger
children because the team we're not
really surprised by anything these days
those reports of a male who just have
repeatedly in the leg
here in the diverse industrial heart of
England we hear from people who have
real stories to tell
parents are going to complain like this
and schools have better get ready for it
these protests are being organized
primarily by people who aren't parents
at the school
so some patients aren't going to survive
this we have to be prepared that
patients will die from from this illness
staff here are currently identifying
wards that could be turned into in areas
where patients with covid-19 could be
isolated
the river 7 is still rising and people
here in Ironbridge have been told it
could go up by another meter before it
starts to go back down
[Music]
it's going to be a long slow process to
put it back together
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
[Music]
oh
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
above the clouds you know why
because this is the Emirates a 380.
[Music]
it's like Emirates slide better
well the big event in markets this
afternoon has been used that U.S
inflation fell from four percent in May
to three percent in June that was lower
than expected and the lowest level since
March 2021 while the news has sent the
U.S dollar lower on hopes that the
Federal Reserve may not need to raise
interest rates up much further uh the
dollar uh currently uh off uh on the
foreign exchange markets by around half
a one percent right now I think against
uh Sterling there you go Panda popped
above 1.30 there uh it's off by around
half of one percent though against the
Euro The single currency meanwhile up by
one percent against the Greenback or the
news has also given a lift to the oil
price that has risen above 80 a barrel
this afternoon for the first time since
the first of May it's back below that
now barrel of breakthrough currently
trading at 79.82 a barrel that's half a
one percent higher on the session on the
equity markets well Wall Street has
opened to the upside the S P 500 the
down the NASDAQ are all ahead by one
percent or more among the features
Amazon up by half of one percent a sales
and its prime Day promotion were up
nearly six percent on last year here's
the situation in Europe that's how the
markets on Continental Europe have
closed here in London the ftse 100 also
up by nearly two percent right now uh
broad-based rally to be honest with you
no specific features that all other
banks have done well on the stress tests
shell and BP have added around 23 points
to the index on their own on the higher
crew price not too many fallers to
mention in the ftse right now but
International Airlines group the owner
of British Airways and their Lingus of
course it's off two and a half percent
on adverse broker comments outside the
ftse 100 the store turn has been JD
Weatherspoon today the pub group up 10
on a trading update there you go ten and
a half percent nearly at the close Royal
mail's owner International distribution
services meanwhile up six and a half
percent after it settled its
long-running dispute with the
communication Workers Union
um I'm afraid we're going to break out
of the market report very very sharply
uh president zielinski has been speaking
at the NATO Summit in Vilnius in the
last few minutes
Terry today said that he told Ukraine
that the UK is not an Amazon style
delivery service for weapons
Ben Wallace also had some advice for
Kiev as you keep on asking for more and
more weapons and support and that was
that people want to see gratitude
how do you respond to that do you think
you're not being grateful enough and are
you worried that you need to be careful
about what you say publicly because if
you complain you could put off the
public or politicians in countries like
the US and elsewhere
clearly understand the questions
I believe that we were always grateful
to United Kingdom we were always
grateful to the prime minister or to
prime ministers
to the minister of defense
because the people
foreign
and uh express our words of gratitude
personally to the minister really I I
don't understand the essence of the
question we are grateful to the United
Kingdom the United Kingdom is our
partner
wants something special but I think that
we have wonderful relations we are very
grateful to the people
[Music]
really the significant support of the
population it has an impact on the
decisions taken by the leadership on the
support of the leadership now because of
the significant support of the British
people to the people of Ukraine I think
this is why we have such a tight
Corporation our intelligence have the
perfect cooperation the Minister of
Defense we have it here well let's see
do you have a problems with your
relationship with the Minister of UK so
why don't you extend words of gratitude
to him
that's great
and you have to call him
yep please today
that was President zielinski speaking to
our defense editor Deborah Haynes well
back to the markets now joining me now
is Hank portsey's Market strategist for
you at the Middle Eastern Africa at
Barclays Private Bank hey good to see
you this afternoon I mean this U.S
inflation number was really quite the
showstopper yeah really good news coming
through price pressures have been eating
in the United States down to three
percent year on year remember that
compares to a peak a year ago of 9.1
they've decelerated for 12 consecutive
months back to their lowest level since
March
2021. what we've seen is the base
effects coming through remember these
are year-on-year comparisons but more
fundamentally than that Goods inflation
service inflation has been calming down
and we think this is a trend that will
continue in fact we've got U.S inflation
averaging 2.3 during the course of next
year why is that important take some of
the pressure off the Federal Reserve
absolutely it does and uh obviously uh
it's results in a bit of a sell-off for
the dollar does that create headwinds
for UK companies doing business there
I'm a little bit I suppose as you see
the impact filtering through in terms of
Foreign Exchange markets when you look
at FX markets they tend to be driven by
interest rate predictions growth rate
projections with an overlay of value now
the US dollar was very strong during the
course of last year because rates were
high the economy was doing better what
we've seen is a real narrowing in terms
of the rate differential and growth
forecasts around those countries that's
why you've seen the dollar weaken we
think that will continue over the course
of the next year now closer to home we
have the bank of England stress test
today I mean obviously there's been a
lot of focus on what the governor said
about mortgages but the banks have come
through this pretty well the thing they
have listen there was a start warning to
mortgage holders about the impact of
higher interest rates we know there's
around about 10 and a half million
residential and buy-to-let mortgages in
the UK eight and a half million of those
were on fixed rate mortgages eight
hundred thousand need to be refinanced
during the course of this year another
1.6 million during the course of next
year so they're going to feel the real
pain of that coming through but actually
what they were talking about the banking
day was the impact it's going to have in
terms of the banks now there were some
fears particularly after all the turmoil
that we saw in the United States we
could be looking at another great
financial crisis playing out but what we
know is that banks are in such a
different position today if you look at
Capital levels they're much much higher
if you look at liquidity it's so much
healthier today leverages come out the
system quite dramatically and as we've
seen the banks are subjected to much
more stringent stress tests so I think
concerns around the failure of a banking
system undermining the global economy
are structurally and dramatically come
down which is good news I guess the read
across for house prices is not so good
it's not so good if you look at UK house
prices they're down around about 4.1
percent compared to the peak that we saw
back in August our expectation is that
we will see further weakness coming
through we will see a correction playing
out we don't think that'll be more than
10 percent Peak to trough decline so yes
there are pressure from higher interest
rates but it should remember UK labor
market Still Remains very strong if you
look at the banks have been stress
testing at much higher levels for
mortgage applicants so I don't think
affordability is the same concern as we
saw back in the 1990s for example
there's also a supply and demand
imbalance in the UK and when I talk to
clients around the world they still love
to invest in UK property markets all
right and got to leave it there great to
see you this afternoon
that's it back from me I'm back at 11 30
tomorrow hope to see you then in the
meantime stay tuned Mark Austin's up
next